foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar evolution
of scale for synthetic oligos I am Matt
Ashton of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more visit thermalfisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send all questions submitted
today will be answered via email
following the broadcast
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
there will be several polls distributed
throughout the webinar your potential
patient is greatly appreciated
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Ben
Hinton senior operations manager genetic
science division life science group
dermo Fisher Scientific then you may now
begin your presentation
okay hello everybody and welcome to the
webinar on the evolution of scale for
oligonucleotides today I'm going to
cover six uh topics
um one is who we are as a company the
second is the evolution of scale from
oligonucleotide synthesis third one
oligonucleotide synthesis from Discovery
work to commercialization uh followed by
small-scale oligonucleotides and their
applications and then large-scale
oligonucleotides their applications and
then why scale up matters
so
who are we
um Thermo Fisher Scientific is a
instrument and consumable
um company who have around about 130 000
um employees
um throughout um the globe
we have a vision to enable our customers
to make the world a healthier cleaner
and safer place
within Thermo Fisher we have 27 years of
experience in oligonucleotide
manufacture covering all of the
different types of oligos primers probes
and Gene synthesis all built to customer
and specifications
we also have an oligo Center of
Excellence within Pleasanton California
um and we are accredited to ISO 19
9001 and 13 485.
my name is Ben I'm the senior manager
for manufacturing operations within the
Pleasanton site
um I have 24 years of experience working
for Therma Fisher spanning various oligo
manufacturing sites within the UK and
within the US
I currently lead the specialty oligo and
custom development and synthesis
um
Lab at Pleasanton
and the next
um topic is the evolution of scale for
oligonucleotide synthesis so in recent
years synthetic DNA oligonucleotides
have enabled novel applications with
development in synthesis Technologies
such scale oligos from this perspective
the webinar will briefly review the
techniques and technologies that enable
the synthesis of large-scale oligos the
challenges that arise with an increase
in scale and emerging applications from
r d to clinical Diagnostics and then
Therapeutics
there are three main learning objectives
throughout this webinar
we want to understand oligosynthesis
from Discovery work to commercialization
help to identify those technical
complexities faced during the scale up
of sequences for our customers and then
make sure that you
um as our customers know what services
and support opportunities Thermo Fisher
Scientific can provide to you and your
company
so let's start at the beginning so what
is oligonucleotide synthesis and how
does it work so oligonucleotide
synthesis hasn't really changed much in
the last 30 years we still use
phosphoramidite chemistry
we start off with a solid support that's
functionalized with the first base or
modification of the sequence
and then we remove the first DNT group
or blocking group from that
functionalized support which enables us
to add the next base with an activator
to that functionalized site that we've
just um deblocked
obviously this
um this reaction is not a hundred
percent
um it's about 98
um efficient and so there are those
shorter sequences that do not get the
next base added so the next step after
activation is capping where we cap those
unreacted sites to prevent further
further extension of those chains
after we've capped those um those uh non
um
those non-reactive sites we then oxidize
the um tri-ester bond to
um create a stable phosphate bond which
will allow us to then repeat the process
of de-blocking that um added ammodate
and then we just repeat that cycle
um over and over again as we add each
base to the synthesis to the the chain
and sequence that has been added
so like I said there's no real
difference between
um the chemistry that we've been using
for the last 30 40 years
um and so small scale and large-scale
synthesis both go through that same
phospho amodite chemistry the difference
really between those two small scale
processes is really how do we how do we
manage those different scale of um
samples
and what challenges come when we scale
up from a small scale synthesis to a
large-scale synthesis and how do we
um how do we manage through those
processes
these oligos are also used in very
varying applications such as PCR and
Target identification for Diagnostic
work
um Therapeutics in aptimers for more
um clinical trials and Therapeutics
so question what scale of oligos do you
currently work with
okay so on this slide I just want to
talk a little bit about small-scale
organ nucleotides and applications
and small scale what is small scale so
when we talk about small scale synthesis
we're really talking about any synthesis
that is less than 10 micromole scale and
it's a manageable scale and the process
is very robust and we can make it a lot
of high throughput platforms we can make
multiple different oligos at a time
um up to
197 oligos on one synthesized platform
so we are consistent repeatable we also
include basic modifications and
purifications as needed for these small
scale oligos
and they have again varying applications
um so one of the main applications that
we would use these um oligos for is
diagnostic testing kits so we would
um create a a probe with a quencher and
a um fluorescent dye for a specific
Target
um sequence within for example a covid
virus
um we would then have the forward and
the reverse primer that is amplifying
that section where the um the probe sits
and as that amplification occurs the
probe will be consumed by the by the
extension of the prime of the primers
and the the fan molecule will float away
and start to fluoresce and it's that
fluorescence that gives you the
the the
um the the signal that there is that
Target sequence within your sample
so this
this PCR reaction this um endpoint
um PCR can you know be used for multiple
different
um
multiple different
applications throughout lots of
different um
sectors of the market
typically a small scale synthesis will
provide a lot of different reactions for
these types of PCR reactions so for
example 25 nanomole synthesis scale
delivers around about a thousand PCR
reactions so you don't really need a lot
of material to get a lot of tests
um how of small scale synthesis so
that's one of the benefits to small
scale synthesis is you get a lot for the
scale that you make it at but it doesn't
always work depending on the application
that you're trying to design for
um small scale synthesis is also very
very established so we are not really
worried about the quality and the um
consistency of the products made on this
process so we spend a lot of time
looking at primer design and Analysis
versus whether or not the oligo is going
to be of a good quality
um and obviously the same synthesis
processes can Aid in the development and
the
um the development and the r d that goes
into these oligo therapies which require
a larger volume of oligo and but for
um but for feasibility studies they are
ideal and so we would start with the
feasibility at a small scale and then
progress within scales as we progress
through the workflow
uh large-scale audio nucleotides are a
completely different
um process
um for us to make a large-scale oligo we
are really talking about 100 grams of
delivered yield and this causes a lot of
increasing complexity we can
um think about how for a large-scale
synthesis
um it's not only the design that is
really important but also how we
manufacture that oligo and how much
sample that we have to deal with and how
we deal with those so for an example for
example to desult a small scale algo
it's really simple we're only really
dealing with one milliliter of sample we
can really easily ethanol precipitate
that sample to remove the salts but when
you've got 20 liters of sample we can't
just do the same process so we have to
think about something different and so
what we do in Thermo Fisher is we have
multiple different processes that we can
use to desult an oligo and as we go
through the development process for
um large-scale synthesis we get to
choose what type of desult or what type
of purification really suits the
application that the customer wants us
to use so we have a lot of knowledge and
a lot of um experience in making those
types of of
decisions as we go through the the
synthesis and the the process with our
customers
um applications for large scale
um oligos are um
usually therapeutic so we have
anti-sense oligos that are made from the
um in the majority of therapies these
are oligos that are short and have the
um have the ability to modify RNA and
reduce and modify protein expression
through several distinct mechanisms by
targeting the source of the pathogen as
opposed to the effects of the pathogen
later in the um
Downstream pathway we also make Optimas
which are synthetic antibodies and are
very very specific to the antigen that
it has been designed to bind to
so why does scale-up matter
well
as I've said there are a lot of
complexities and technical issues that
we have when scaling from small scale
all the way up to large scale
and what that transition translates to
from a customer's perspective is that
customers sometimes do not have the
internal technical knowledge to
understand why things can
it can be different when they're looking
at a feasibility study using a small
scale logo to a
um a therapeutic um batch size of
large-scale
um audio so
um that is something that we're very
used to working through as a company and
we also can sit down with our customers
talk about the capacities and the
timeline of doing the scaling
um
efforts from small scale to Grammy
yields for their um their application
and also sometimes understanding of
those regulatory requirements is uh
difficult to get to because we're
looking at what those
Therapeutics are used for so do we need
endotoxin testing and do we need bio
bullet burden and our analysis
um so these are those conversations that
we can have with with our customers to
decide which is the best process to use
as we scale up
um and that's where the solution comes
through so you really need a dedicated
technical project team to really be able
to answer those questions that you have
and to be able to explain the
differences between
um this the small scale and the large
scale and explain why we need to do
things a different way and how we're
going to do that
um
we also make sure that we are you know
governed by the ISO standards we are
13485
um registered and we are able to get
that repeatability uh that our customers
need and we also do analytical analysis
on all of our Lots
um uh depending on the customer
requirements as well
so
um for the next couple of slides I'm
just going to talk through some case
studies that we've had
um in the last few years
um
I just want to use these to um highlight
some of those technical complexities
that we can encounter when we are
deciding to scale up our sequences
excuse me
so
um the first case study one of our
customers needed a really complex
backbone modified oligo which included
very different modifications LNA bases
um a photo cleavable um spacer and they
wanted a really high Purity above 90
with various different fluorescent diet
attachments obviously
these oligos are very complex
um and
um the scale-up method was
um was something that we had to really
think about how do how do we do what
we're being asked to do so
we had a partnership with the customer
within a few weeks we'd sat down we'd
talked and discussed with the customer
what their actual needs were
I'd worked with our manufacturing
Sciences team and our development team
to come up with a process that was going
to deliver exactly what the requirements
were and within a few weeks of
establishing that the client received
their first milligram of product
we sent that to the customer so that
they could test to make sure that the
quality that they needed was fit for
their purpose
um and they came back and said that it
was very good quality Superior to
Quality they were getting before and
then they placed some more pilot orders
for some other
samples and throughout some other scales
to try and assess what skill scale they
really needed in order to satisfy their
demand and their forecast going forward
so one of the benefits that that
conversation and that that partnership
that we had with the customer was that
we could really get down to what
specifications did our customers really
require and what were unique for us to
meet that project's needs
um we set out a very
[Music]
um
very clear that and delivery timeline uh
which meant that we may were able to
meet that and our customers knew exactly
when they were going to get their oligos
for testing and then when they were
going to be able to get the next pilot
order for them to work on as well and we
also were able to set up a long-term
pricing model because we did have a
forecast from the customer so we were
able to understand what the requirements
going forward were and how that would
affect our capacity within the lab
so the outcome of this particular
um order and this particular partnership
was that the client was able to bring
their technology to Market on time and
well within their budget
so that was a real good example of when
working together closely with the
customer really paid dividends both for
um for for our team here in Pleasanton
and also for the customer that's
why
um another case study
um this is
um a biotech customer that needed a
really large scale complex GC Rich
unmodified sequence with really high
Purity
um and a lot of analytical testing after
the fund
so the client really wanted to ensure
that we could deliver an oligar that was
ready for their analytical testing
within a really tight timeline
we did have some um technical issues
with this oligo
um it was very g-rich and the scale was
very very high so we started off making
around about one to two grams of the
oligo
um and we did that with the pilot bills
within I think uh three weeks
um and satisfied all of the Purity
requirements that the customer wanted
and all of the analytical testing that
was required and delivered that to the
customer
uh they were happy with that and came
back for a higher scale so we we needed
then to scale up to 10 grams per build
um and when we started to do this we
came across quite a few
um
technical issues so the G Rich oligo had
a secondary structure that really became
prevalent as the scale increased and so
we had to change our process to adapt to
how we were going to resolve the
purification problems that came with
having a secondary structure on such a
large scale oligar so we changed the
synthesis strategy
um we adapted the purification method so
that we could purify
um a try it out on oligo and then we had
to introduce another couple of steps to
remove trital and then to desalt that
I'll go using ultra filtration
um but those changes
um were communicated to the customer we
talked through the reasons why we had to
make those changes and then implemented
them
um for the uh the large-scale 10 gram
build which was successful
um and then we we moved on and now have
a a process in place that allows us to
deliver those oligos and those types of
oligos
um regularly and um relatively
straightforwardly now that the process
is in place so again another benefit of
working very closely with the customer
is that we get to know exactly what
those
customers
um need from a specification point of
view so another thing that these that
this customer specifically asked for was
biobird in testing Ash content analysis
and heavy metal analysis which as a
company we hadn't done before so we then
reached out to other vendors and found
another third-part party vendor that
could carry out those tests for us so
that we could take it off our customers
hands so before we even ship to the
customer we make sure that we meet all
of those testing criteria uh for their
hour ago we take all of that burden off
the customer and we take it in-house and
then we make sure that we're delivering
um what they need
um and the outcome of that is that the
client scaled up to multi-gram Lots
um for their application and then came
back to us for with um
multiple other sequences that they
wanted us to scale up as well
so would you like to connect with our
technical team to learn more about our
capabilities for oligosynthesis scale
foreign
okay so in order for us to
um help our customers with the scale up
we have put together a checklist I'm
going to walk through that
um now because it's very important and
it really does help you as the customer
and us as the manufacturer to make sure
that we're delivering exactly what you
guys need
so the first thing is you need to have
the right support
um we have technical project teams that
are skilled in all your development and
capacity management
so that team will reach out and collect
the requirements from the customer and
do an initial technical assessment if we
feel that we have to reach out to the
customer and sit down with them and go
through step by step then we will do and
if we feel that we are in a place where
we can put a quote together with those
specifications then we can send a quote
and discuss with the with the customer
afterwards if if needed
we need to make sure that all those
Quality Systems are in place within all
development and production Labs
um
and that any pilot order that we do
manufacture for our client is
manufactured under those
um Quality
um systems and properly documented
we then would send the client the
customer the oligo for testing and if
that goes successfully then
um we would continue to provide the
customer with their their
material and if not then we still have
this feedback loop where we can go back
and we can discuss any technical
challenges that the customer sees
although we've had throughout
manufacture and make changes if need so
development really is an iterative
process and flexibility on both sides is
a necessary necessary for for the scale
after we've gone through that whole
process then the scale up is in place
and we were able to do um to provide the
material that our customer needs
so um Thermo Fisher Scientific services
and support
um we do have a lot of support uh
functions that are available to our
customers we have very very strong
technical teams that are able to jump on
a call
answer emails and answer questions that
our customers have we have a hundred
years of combined experience throughout
the team
um to uh draw upon and we are able to
make anywhere from a couple of
milligrams a while ago all the way up to
100 gram capacity really we have a
dedicated ordering of fulfillment system
service that are integrated with your
systems and processes we have ISO 9001
and ISO 13 485 compliance Quality
Management Systems as I said before
um customer service and Technical
Support teams that are there to help you
um with your
um with your needs and requirements
um would you like a quote on your Custom
oligo Design
foreign
okay so are you ready to get started are
you interested in having a conversation
with our technical team
below are three easy steps that have
been listed to make it easy for you to
reach out to our technical teams and
start your technical evaluation
step one make sure that you have all of
your specifications and Technical
requirements such as delivered yield
Purity modifications Etc
um with you and then reach out to our um
a small scale logo team if it's just a
standard oligar you can order them at
the links below
um and inquiries email address that is
um referenced there and one of our
technical project managers will reach
out to you within one to two business
days to start your project kickoff
the third step is that your technical
project manager will work with our
manufacturing Sciences team to do
determine feasibility timeline and the
price they will send you a comprehensive
quote and work within your budget and
timeline
any questions today
and thank you all for listening
thank you Ben for your informative
presentation and your time today we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor thermal Fisher Scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye